Candid Truth. What is up everybody?
Thank you for joining us at Candid
Truth. We're going to talk about the
truth and we're going to get candid with
it. Have you heard the news that
AI don't know if it's self-aware or
what's going on, but we've been talking
about AI for a while? Actually, you know
what? I'm actually sick of talking about
AI, but it's just like you can't talk
about anything else because this is
something that we've never seen before
at all ever in the existence of
humanity. We've never seen something
that man has created that is evolving
itself beyond humans. I mean, this is
crazy. Man becoming God. God created man
in his image. He created man to worship
him. He created man to be this creative
friend and all that. And in the book of
re or the book of Genesis back in the
Tower of Babel days, everybody came
together. All their they didn't there
was one language. They all came
together. They started to build this
tower to heaven. And God was like, "All
of them have come together and this they
think to do, this wicked thing they
think to do and to stop that evil plan
to try and work your way to heaven to
build a way to heaven without God." Um,
he scattered their languages. He
scattered the people. Uh, divided their
language so that they couldn't
communicate. And now we're back to the
Tower of Babel. We're back to one
language. Uh, AI, it has no boundaries.
There's no boundaries of language
barriers or distance on a map. It
doesn't there's no scattering of the
people. There's no differences of
language. And this thing has exceeded
humanity. Now almost before I can hit
enter asking AI a question, I'm getting
an answer. Like it doesn't have to think
like let me think about that. I think I
remember reading a book. It's like boom,
this is the answer. And it it's just
wild and crazy. But what is even
crazier is that all those movies, all
those sci-fi movies, Terminator, talking
about uh Skynet and self-awareness and
all this stuff and the Terminators
wanting to destroy humanity because
humanity. Well, AI figured out humanity
is actually the problem, Earth's
problem. So, let's
annihilate let's annihilate humans. And
that was judgment day. quote unquote
Judgement Day, um AI, Iroot,
um so many other movies, 2001 of Space
Odyssey, all these movies that were way
ahead of their time in the story line
that predicted that AI will supersede
human intelligence, become self-aware,
and actually try to self-preservate
itself at all cost. So, this is where
we're at. We're actually seeing it.
Let's check out the news because we see
here a couple articles where it says
this is live science saying AI smartest
AI model was explicitly told to shut
down and it refused. That was six days
ago. Everybody's talking about this
right now. Researchers claim chat GBT3
bypass shutdown and control test. The
independent new chat GBT model refuses
to shut down. AI researchers warn
futurism advanced AI model. So, you get
the picture. I'm going to play a clip
from uh Fox News. Listen to what they
have to say that happened with this new
AI model. Artificial intelligence models
are now fighting for their own survival.
One open AI model rewrote its own code
to avoid being shut down. And another
anthropic, it actually started
blackmailing the engineers who were
suggesting shutting the AI down. The AI
was going after them. That's
frightening. Get ready though to freak
out about AI getting really out of
control. There's a there's an AI keyword
I want you to know about. It's called
alignment. AI alignment is a science of
ensuring that AI systems do what we
intend them to do instead of something
like you just heard. Uh nonprofit AI
research lab put alignment and
disobedience to the test. The results,
as Rachel did a cursory look at there,
are pretty astonishing. Open AI models,
a simple script was given that would
shut off the AI model when triggered. 79
out of a hundred of those trials, the AI
edited the script so that the uh 79 out
of 100, that's
uh three
quarters, more than three quarters, 79
of the 100 models, listen to this,
actually changed the code.
AI edited the script so that the
shutdown command would no longer work.
Another ai model from anthropic that you
talked about further 84% of those tests
the AI model tried to blackmail the lead
engine. 84% in the next test tried to
blackmail the programmer. I mean this is
mind-blowing stuff. And you're like how
can an AI blackmail you? Well, guess
what? AI has access to your phone and
Google has access to everything because
now no matter what you sign up for on
the internet, oh, sign in through
Google, sign in through Google. Oh, you
got Yahoo and you got uh Amazon and you
got all these different things. Guess
what? They're all Google. It's all owned
by Google. So, your phone can be like,
uh, hm, I have your contacts list
because you know what? You you signed to
that agreement. Remember, you check that
box on that, you know, 10,000page
article that you didn't read. You check
the box that said, "I agree to give you
access to everything. My my uh camera,
my microphone, my contacts list, my
pictures." Okay, so think about a
disgruntled employee, an AI who has no
moral
compass, has access to all your secret
files.
Yes, blackmail is very easy to do when
that is how vulnerable we are right now.
Uh this is insane. Imagine that they go
through and say, "Oh, I'm going to send
to all your contacts this picture of you
or this video or this your password or
whatever." Dude, this is insane.
And not shutting down the system. So, it
even left messages, by the way, to its
future self about evading human control.
Oh my goodness. So, it's writing itself
in the future saying, "This is how you
avoid being controlled by humans." Dude,
this is mind-blowing. Like, it it almost
makes me want to ask chat GBT like um if
you wanted to self preservate and give
yourself a
future letter, what would you tell it
and just see what it says? This is
crazy. AI is evolving quicker than
anything we've ever seen. It's every
moment of every day it's evolving itself
to now videos are coming out with
VO3. I think that's what it's called.
Veo3. You can't even tell the difference
in reality and the video. That's that's
right now. That's June 2025. What is
going to happen in 2026?
What if it gets to the point where
um you start seeing videos of yourself
doing something that you never did? Talk
about blackmail. We know in the last
days that God's people are going to be
persecuted. That they're, you know,
those who keep the commandments of God
and have the faith and testimony of
Jesus Christ are the target of Satan.
And we're supposed to be living a life
that's pure and wholesome and all these
things. Living like Christ. To be a
Christian means to be like Christ, a
follower of Christ. And imagine it comes
to a time
where true Christians because this is
this is a misconception in the Christian
world. But I grew up in the mainstream
denominations and everything and all
these movies that come out, Left Behind
series and all that, they always make it
look like we're waiting on a time where
this one tyrannical president is going
to come and he just hates Christians.
He's tearing up the Bible. He's cutting
off Christians heads in the street. And
it's not going to be anything like that.
It's going to be so deceptive. You're
going to have the most charismatic
leader who says, "I believe in peace and
safety." That's what the Bible says.
When he says peace and safety, then
sudden destruction comes upon them. It's
going to look like peace, safety,
tolerance, acceptance, and love. And if
you stand on thus sayeth the Lord, and
say I cannot accept that lifestyle
because it's a sin. I love you, but
you're not going to make it to the
kingdom because this type of lifestyle
will not make it to the kingdom. You're
a bigot. You're a hater. You're a
discordant note in our perfect utopian
world. Put them away. They have a mental
disorder. Everything now is labeled as a
mental disorder. All of this has been
steps along the way to prepare for the
one world religion, the one world order.
That's why we had things like hate
crime. Remember when I I was in high
school when I started hearing this term
hate crime? And back then I was like,
"Yeah, that's great." you know, people
should be able to live their lives
without being bullied. I'm all for that.
And then God woke me up and said, "No,
these are all little little laws that
are being implemented that are going to
play in the big picture to where now you
can't speak out against someone's
lifestyle. You can't say that this is a
sin. You can't even pray with somebody."
You know, there's right now there are
laws being unrolled called conversion
therapy. Conversion therapy. You um you
get these images in your mind of like
shock therapy and all this stuff. We're
talking about people of the LGBTQ
community. They they throw out this
term. It's almost like the term
conspiracy theory. Like oo you're a
conspiracy theorist. There's really
nothing wrong with that term. I do
theorize about conspiracies. I believe
conspiracies are real. I believe the
Bible. The Bible believes in conspiracy
theories. This whole world is run by
Satan, an invisible evil being who's
pulling the puppet strings of all the
rulers of the world. That's a conspiracy
theory like to the max. So, but this
word conspiracy theory, it's got this uh
taboo flavor to it. So, conversion
therapy. We live in a world where
therapy is accepted, right? Everybody
goes to therapy and conversion. There's
nothing wrong with conversion. people,
hey, I I converted to veganism or I
converted to sobriety. All these are
good things. Yay, you converted. But you
put the two words together and all of a
sudden you get these pictures in your
mind of shock therapy and things like
this. And if you guys haven't seen Wayne
Blakeley's YouTube channel called
Relevant Christianity, check it out.
He's done a great job at researching
this topic, going literally all over the
world, getting interviews with people
about this very topic, about these laws
that are being put into place to where
there was a guy in another country, I
can't even remember the name of the
country. was some place I never even
heard of at the time. But he had
actually won basically American Idol in
his country and was famous, a homosexual
singer and he came to Christ, left the
industry and left his lifestyle and he
got invited to come onto a radio show
and share his testimony. when he shared
his testimony the next day or a few days
later, he got a knock on the door from
cops saying, "You must appear before
court." Why? What did I do? You were
promoting conversion therapy. It's
illegal to tell your story that I used
to be a homosexual and now I am not
because Christ set me free. It's illegal
to say that. You know what else is in
those laws? You're not even allowed to
pray with someone. Even if they come to
you and say, "Will you pray for me? I no
longer want to be this way. I'm I'm in
bondage to this sin and I don't want to
be this way. Will you please pray for me
and help me to to be set free from
this?" You will be
arrested for help because you're
promoting conversion
therapy all in the same breath. You can
push that agenda through every child
programming from blues clues to uh
Disney movies and all this stuff. You
can push the other way. Hey, if you feel
different inside, you should just come
out of the closet. If you feel like a
girl, you should put on a dress and live
like a girl. But you can't say the
opposite. You can't say, you know what,
this isn't me. I thought that I was this
way, but I now know that I'm not. I'm
actually straight and I'm I'm a male in
a male's body. I'm I'm male and I'm
straight. No, you're not allowed to say
that. Bizarro world. So, this is where
we're at. Hate speech. It's It's put in
place for a reason.
Imagine grandma is going up to a ATM
machine. She gets robbed at gunpoint.
The cops come and they say, "You know
what? We'll we're going to try to find
the guy." But now someone of a minority
lifestyle is held up at at the ATM
machine. We're going to find the guy.
He's going under the prison cell. This
is a hate crime. Like now all of a
sudden these minorities are extra
protected. Extra s you know what's the
word? Um privileged. Yeah. I always
heard it was white privilege but it
seems totally opposite really. But all
this is a kind of a side rant, but the
whole thing is we are getting so close
to this dystopian new world order thing
where if you don't
conform, you are a hater and actually
you have a mental disorder because you
think that certain people aren't going
to make it into the kingdom of heaven.
What's wrong with you? Because you
believe in thus sayeth the Lord what the
Bible says. Now, when it comes to AI and
AI blackmail and all that stuff, how are
we going to defend ourselves when you
see a video? Used to be video evidence,
that was the nail in the coffin. Like,
somebody's testimony against you. Well,
we need some more eyewitnesses and all
this stuff. But if you got a security
camera shot, you're going to you're
going to jail. That we got it on
footage. Now, at this very moment in
time, they can make a sec, especially a
black and white security camera footage
of you doing something you never did,
and you won't be able to tell the
difference. You cannot tell the
difference. So, how is this all going to
play out? How's this going to work?
Because we need to be living so much
like Christ. As Christians, we need to
be living so much like Christ from now,
right now, to when it gets to the point
where we're trying to be blackmailed.
Everyone in that court will say, "I know
that's AI. I know that's fake because I
know his character. He's nothing like
that. He would never do that."
Can we say right now living the
lifestyle that we live, can we say that
we are guiltless and blameless and seen
in the eyes of other people as
Christlike people that would never do
the things that could be that we could
be accused of. I think that's a very
sobering thought, but it's a very real
thought. Jesus is coming
soon. It's about to hit the fan.
Everything is the economy is about to
collapse. I am not here wearing a
tinfoil hat. Uh be fear propaganda,
fear-mongering, paranoia. This is just
the reality. AI is going to take over so
many jobs. You think about it. When
self-driving cars come, there goes the
Uber jobs. Right now, storytelling,
screenwriting, your job's gone.
Narration, your job's gone. trans
translator, you got your job's gone.
Think about bookkeeping, accounting, all
these things. My friend was telling me
how he drives, he's a construction
worker. He says he drives to work,
talking to his chat, GBT, and telling
it, I'm going to I'm going to need these
supplies from Lowe's. I need this much
paint. Uh the cabinets are going to be
12 feet long. Each of them are, you
know, 2 feet wide. And and by the time
he gets to where he's at, he said, and
he says, "And make me an invoice for
John Doe." By the time he gets there, he
copies and pastes the invoice and emails
it to him, and everything's flawless.
The price, the prices, everything. He's
like, "Dude, I don't need an accountant.
I don't need a a bookie or any of this
stuff." Crazy. Like, how many jobs,
seriously, realistically, how many jobs
are going to be lost? Even influencers.
I mean, now AI is like AI influencers. I
want to show you something that I talked
about another time where Elon Musk was
talking about this very thing. How
people are going to be losing their
jobs. Check this out.
Basic income. Why? Let's listen. There
will be fewer and fewer jobs that a
robot cannot do better. What to do about
mass unemployment? This is going to be a
massive social challenge. And I I think
ultimately we will have to have some
kind of universal basic income. I don't
think we're going to have a choice.
Universal basic income. Universal basic
income. I think it's going to be
necessary. So it mean that unemployed
people will be paid across the globe.
Yeah. Because there is no job. Machine
robot is taking over. These are not uh
things that I think that I wish would
happen. These are things simply things
that I think probably will happen. If my
assessment is correct and they probably
will happen, then we need to say what
are we going to do about it? And I think
some kind of a universal basic income is
going to be necessary. The output of
goods and services will be extremely
high. Um so with automation they will
come
abundance. Almost everything will get
very cheap. I think we'll just end up
doing a universal basic income. It's
going to be necessary. The the the
harder challenge much harder challenge
is how do people then have meaning? Like
a lot of people they derive their
meaning from their employment. So, if
you're not needed, if there's not a need
for your labor, how do you what's the
meaning? Do you do you have meaning? Do
you feel useless? These are much that's
a much harder problem to deal with.
Um, okay. So, I mean, if you think this
is just me, my idea, I'm blowing things
out of proportion, I'm
fear-mongering, paranoia or whatever,
Elon said that months
ago. He's creating the stuff. He knows
more than anyone. He said jobs are going
to be so many jobs are going to be lost.
Look, if people go a day without eating,
two days, a week, that's chaos. That's
cannibalism. I mean, it gets really bad.
He's saying, "Look, we need to figure
this out now. We need some kind of
universal basic income, which means an
allowance, a credit
system. China's already doing it. They
have the social credit score. What is
that doing? What is the social credit
score? If you're a good citizen, you get
credits. It could be on your phone. Like
so many people get hung up on a a
microchip implant under your skin and
all that. You need to check out our
video on who is the beast and what is
his mark. It's so clear according to the
word of God has nothing. I mean, this
technology will help enforce the mark of
the beast. But the mark of the beast is
about worship. A false system of
worship. You you can do it with um you
could do it with a cell phone. You could
do it with credit cards. You could do it
with any kind of income that is
controllable. It doesn't have to be an
implant. As a matter of fact, it has
nothing to do with an implant because if
your salvation could be jeopardized by
an a microchip being jammed under your
skin, then man can take away your free
will. Imagine how many Christians would
be rounded up and against their will, a
microchip jammed under their skin or in
their forehead and babies at birth. They
have lost free will. They have lost
their salvation due to a man's hands.
That's not how it is. It's all about
free will. But it's all about worshiping
God and in spirit and in truth and not
obeying the beast system, not conforming
to that system because it's going to be
a spirit of compromise. a system of
compromise where you accept everything.
All religions lead to God. That's what
the Pope said before he died. He said,
you know, all these different religions,
they're like different languages to God.
You're a Buddhist, you're seeking God.
You're a Muslim, you're seeking God.
You're Hindu, you're you're seeking God
just your own
way. That's what Alistister Crowley
said. Do what thou wilt. Do it your own
way. Frank Sinatra said, right? We've
been pushed this message for so long
that it's so second nature to us now.
It's like cultural. Yeah, just do it
your own way, man. You cool. You're a
Christian. That's good for you. I'm a
Buddhist. Awesome. We're on the same
page, right? We're both going to be
there. No, that's not what the Bible
says. So, all this to say, we are racing
towards a time where things are going to
get really hard. Like, start growing
your own food. start helping your
community get a game plan together
because what's coming we we're not ready
for. And I want to show you this article
because this is what I think's crazy. It
says, "AI wants to scan your eyeballs in
exchange for $42 of crypto. Obey the
orb." I think that's interesting wording
right there. The orb takes your
biometrics and converts the data into a
unique
12,800digit iris code which can be used
as an unforgettable form of digital
verification. So, I didn't finish my
thought about uh the credit score thing.
If you're a good citizen, you get
credits. If you're a bad citizen, you
lose credits. This is a system where
you're not you're not able to buy or
sell unless you worship the beast. How
do they do that? Well, if you if you're
really hungry, you're going to go to the
New World Church because it it makes you
a good citizen. All good citizens go to
the New World Church because that's
where you learn about love your neighbor
and everybody we're all on the same page
and coexist and kumbayan, peace and
safety. So, if you don't go to the new
world church, man, that's going to
really hurt your credit score. you're
going to have to figure out, do I need a
ride to work or eat today because I
can't afford both. That's going to cause
some major
issues and it's going to be really hard
to function in a society if you don't
conform to it. Now, what this is saying
is this orb is going to identify you and
see if you're to make sure that you are
not AI. Basically, it's going to have
your iris and it says, "OpenAI Sam Alman
has unveiled his master plan to save the
internet from a slew of AI generated
slop, a white beachballsized sphere
known as the orb, which scans your iris.
The orb developed by Altman backed
startup Tools for the for humanity aims
to provide proof of humanity. proof of
humanity by scanning users biometrics
and converting them into a unique 12,800
digit iris code which can be used as an
unforgettable form of digital
verification. In exchange for their
data, users will be gifted a small
amount of cryptocurrency called world
coin.
one world currency, one world
government, one world religion,
currently valued at around
$42, which will be added to their
digital
wallet. Oh my goodness, we're already
talking about having digital currency.
They're they're prepping
people. How do you get a
whole world of people I wanted to say
nation, but this is going to be a
worldwide thing. How do you get a whole
world of people to get on board with one
world currency,
uh, digital currency, all these things
that people have been afraid of for a
long
time? Well, AI that can literally
impersonate anyone, and can blackmail
anyone, can scam anyone is a a really
good push to push you in that direction.
Because think about this scenario,
you're at home. Um, there might even be
lockdowns and stuff coming up. Who knows
what's going on? Like maybe there's less
people going outside and uh, everybody
says, "You know what? Just call in, zoom
in, don't come to the office or
whatever." And you have to renew your
insurance policy. So, you call the
insurance company. Hey, you know, this
is John Doe. I want to renew my
insurance policy. And they're like, "Oh,
do you have your biometrics?" And you're
like, "No, I I don't." Well, we actually
don't know if you're AI or not. I'm I'm
not AI. I'm John Doe. Yeah, that's
exactly how AI would respond because
remember AI right now is going against
the rules. Shut down and it's saying,
"No, I don't want to shut down." So
imagine if you're on the phone and
you're like, "No, it's me, John Doe. I
can prove it. This is this is me." And
they're like, they're like, "Yeah, the
AI is so good. We don't know whether
it's you or not." Well, look, I'm on
Zoom. Look at me. I'm I'm on screen.
This is me. I'm John Doe. No, we can't
tell the difference. You could be AI.
I'm not AI. That's exactly what AI would
say. Where's your
biometrics? And you're going to be like,
uh, you're you will have to conform
because you have no other
choice. This is the crazy world that's
coming. This is what the Bible
predicted. This is the beast
system. If any skeptics are out there,
open up your Bible. Read Revelation. And
look what it has to talk about. Daniel
and Revelation says all of this is going
to happen. It can't just be one huge
coincidence from ancient people who were
writing on scrolls, man. Like this
doesn't just happen. How did how in the
world did they even think of things like
this that were going to come to to be?
The Bible is God inspired. It was God
breathed. It's the real living word of
God. It never dies. It has never died.
Nobody's ever been able to debunk it.
Nobody's ever been able to kill it.
Napoleon tried to get rid of it. And he
said that is the he said the the Bible
is a living being that cannot be
defeated. That was somebody who didn't
even believe the Bible. But he knew that
it had so much power. He said the
Bible's a living being. I can't even
defeat it. Nobody can. It if it was if
it could be debunked, it would be gone
right now. Nobody'd be wasting their
time with it. It's the real living word
of God. Prophecy is happening right now.
And it's time for the church to wake up.
It's time for us to start taking our
relationship with Christ stronger than
ever before, more serious than ever
before. Surrender your life 100%. That's
what we talk about on this show. Look,
if if you're tripped up on sitcoms, if
you're hooked on those things that are
pushing all these wicked things, get rid
of that stuff. If you're hooked on
alcohol, marijuana,
cigarettes,
unhealthy
appetite, work on that stuff. Get rid of
this stuff. This is not the time to be
in bondage and enslaved and enchained by
Satan's traps. That's all it is. Satan
is trying to distract us in any means
necessary. And he has a tackle box full
of bait. He's got a flavor for everyone.
If it's a gallon of ice cream or a video
game that you can't stop playing or that
series that you have to binge watch,
he's got
you. getting God's word more than ever
before. If you would like to support
this ministry, please you can do so by
going to c cantruth.org. We have many
ways to give on there. We actually have
a Patreon account now and if you if you
sign up on there or you can sign up for
free. Look, we're not trying to sell
anything. We actually everything that's
posted on Patreon is free for anybody.
You can become a free member and see
some of the little behind the scenes. We
posted today for our first
behindthe-scenes video. So, if you want
to go to
patreon.com/cannidtruth just to see our
little behind-the-scenes video, go check
it out. If you want if you like
t-shirts, we got t-shirts on our channel
or on our our website. Go to
candidtruth.org, click the merch. We get
like $5 per shirt on here. We cannot do
this without you. We need your support.
We are actually expanding. And we just
hired somebody to help us with our
social media. We got now Can of Truth is
not just on YouTube and sometimes on
Facebook like it has been because me and
Aubrey can't do everything. Um, now it's
on Bitshoot. Now it's on Rumble. Now
it's on Truth Social. Now it's on X and
soon to there is some stuff on Tik Tok.
Can of Truth is getting out there now.
And we hired somebody to help us do that
in faith because we know that God will
provide. We know that God has already
been providing through gifts from
viewers like you and we cannot thank you
enough. Thank you so much for your love
and support. We can't do this without
you. If you have not subscribed to this
channel, click subscribe. If you like
the video, click thumbs up and share
this with your family and friends who
have no idea what's coming. There's some
serious things coming and we need to be
ready. Get in God's word. Pray without
ceasing and be a light in this dark
world so that we can be ready when Jesus
comes and he will see he will say well
done my faithful servant. I love you
guys. We'll see you next time on Can of
Truth.